Look at these high waisted work pants.
Look, they're so stretchy,
they're so comfortable.
They have pockets,
but no pockets in the back,
so just, like, hugs your curves,
do you know what I mean?
And the zippers, not really there.
There's no need for the zipper.
So it's natural,
bulky and bunchy right here.
I throw it out of, like, a cute little loose top.
I just love a wide leg pant with, like, a baggy shirt.
Just like, giving the vibes of just elegance.
And then I put on a little cardigan
when I wanna look kind of professional.
But when I wanna go out,
I just make sure the shirt is really cute.
Doing,
like, these pants,
I love them. They're so hot,
it doesn't even feel like I'm in, like,
work pants and trying to be professional.
I am 5 9 and I'm 160 pounds.
I'm very mid size.
I'm not. I may look small,
but I'm not a teeny tiny girl.
I got a size large.
I literally broke out the tape measure,
measured my waist,
my hips, my legs.
I got a size large.
They hug all the right places,
but they, you know,
give me room to breathe.
There is a huge discount for first time orders in the TikTok shop.
The link is below.
There's free shipping and free returns.